[MUSIC PLAYING]
DONNA KENNEDY: Thank
you so much, guys,
for taking the time to be here.
I'm delighted to be here.
But more importantly,
hopefully I
will impact at least one person
here, ideally all of you.
But I would like to
impact one person at least
so that when you
leave here, you go out
with a better mindset and a
better attitude towards life
and also towards your career.
Does that sound good?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DONNA KENNEDY: Wonderful.
So I'm just going to tell
you a little bit about me.
And then I'm going to
tell you where I was
and how I bridged
the gap in between.
Because all of us want to
get somewhere in our lives,
whether that be in
our personal lives
or whether it be in
business or a career.
But sometimes we just
don't know how to do that.
So I'm all about the how
because at one point in my life,
I didn't have the how.
I just had a wish.
So I'm just going to
show you a little bit
about my life at the moment.
And this is my little boy.
And at Christmas,
this is how eager
he was to get his presents.
And I just love doing
anything to do with adrenalin.
But on the flip side,
I love doing art.
I love media stuff,
anything really
that gives me a
little bit of a buzz
or a feeling of
purpose for life.
That's me.
At one point in my
life, this was me.
So I was literally half
the weight I am now.
So if you imagine
if you split me
down the middle, what you get,
I know that's hard to believe.
I know it's horrible.
But this basically was this,
A physical representation
of [INAUDIBLE] need and a
response to my environment.
That's all it was.
Can everybody see here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DONNA KENNEDY: Yeah?
OK.
So that's what it was.
And sometimes, I know
this is physical graphic
representation.
And not all of us
go on that route.
But our responses, our
behaviors can be as destructive.
It could be anything
from procrastination
to alcohol abuse,
drug abuse, being shy,
not putting yourself forward.
All those things are just
results of unmet needs
and our reaction to
our environments.
Because would you agree--
have you ever met
a negative baby?
No?
You know when people say,
oh, I'm just a worrier.
Have you ever met a worrier
baby or an anxious baby
or a baby who is just one
of those pessimistic people?
[LAUGHTER]
Never.
So we're born happy
and successful.
We're just conditioned
over time not to be.
And I'm going to show
you proof of that
and how you can actually
rise above that conditioning
and become the best
versions of yourself
because that's what I want
here for you today is become
a better version of yourself.
It's not up to me to decide what
it is you want in your life,
but I'm going to help
you to get there.
This is what I want
you to understand--
life happens.
Every single person
here has had an event
in their life that
they haven't liked,
some small event,
some big event.
But you can't really
compare a pain.
You can't really
compare events as such.
But everybody has had
some thing in life
that has halted them
to stop them becoming
the person that they
really are truly
capable of becoming and
reaching their full potential.
And I'm going to tell you
this actually happened to me
more than once.
And it's good to know that
because sometimes when you
become successful-- and
by successful I mean being
the best you can be--
sometimes when you
become successful,
you think you've made it.
And all of sudden you're flung
back to the way you were.
So people often ask me, why
is it that I put in my body
like that?
It's not out of vanity.
That is not attractive.
Would you all agree?
I put myself like that because
when I was seven, I was raped.
And I didn't know
what to do with it.
So I kept it in my mind, and
that was the result of it.
OK, I'm going to
flip from that image
because it's not
very nice to look at.
But that was the result of it.
My life just went
totally out of control.
So because I
couldn't control it,
I came upon this thing called
getting the numbers down
on the scale.
And that happened to be it.
I felt in control of my life.
Control is a norm of human need.
If it's thrown off
balance, we do everything
that we can to get it met.
And we have lots of other needs.
And if we can't, we go for
the second best alternative.
And that's why we all go for
second best alternatives when
our needs aren't met.
So eventually I did get better.
And the only reason I'm
telling him my story
is not to impress you or to
show you where I am today.
It's to impress upon
you that no matter where
you are or what
you are doing, you
can get what you want
with the right mindset,
the right skills, and
the right attitude.
Skills and strategies can
be learned very easily.
It's your attitude and your
mindset that actually predict
how well you use those skills.
So when I got better, and
I genuinely was better,
I was healthy.
I was in [INAUDIBLE].
I had a boyfriend.
I thought I had it made.
And relatively [INAUDIBLE],,
I was going out.
I was [INAUDIBLE] school,
too, jumping off the pier
during school.
I really, really was
healthy and productive.
I got into first
year in college.
It took a lot because
of psychology.
It was very competitive,
believe it or not.
And I thought I had it made.
And then in 1998, I
had a car accident,
and I hit my head during
that car accident.
I hit it here on the
side, my temporal lobe.
And about two weeks
later, I started
to experience funny symptoms.
I was losing track of time.
I just wasn't myself.
And I was also hearing
mumbles in my mind.
So I said to my mom,
I know there's nothing
psychologically wrong with me.
But there's something not right.
And she said, yeah, I agree.
So go to the doctor.
So I went to the doctor
and the doctor said to me
take antidepressants.
And I said, but
I'm not depressed.
And I genuinely wasn't because
I had overcome all that stuff.
And what they said,
well, take them anyway.
He automatically jumped
to the conclusion
that it was because of
my earlier years, where
I guess I was feeling low.
So I took the antidepressants.
Long story short, I ended
up in the psychiatric unit
two weeks later on
24-hour supervision, which
means if I walk over here,
I have a human shadow.
If I go to the bathroom,
if I have a shower,
I have somebody
literally following me.
They told my parents
that I had schizophrenia.
I had to go on the
medication, the highest dose
as quickly as possible
and to be committed
on 24-hour supervision.
Both I and my parents knew
I didn't have schizophrenia.
But at the time, my
parents had used up
the insurance from my earlier
years, so they couldn't use it.
You can't use the same insurance
on the same illness as such.
So they didn't
have the insurance
to cover my hospital stay
to get a second opinion.
So I was there.
In three months, I was on
14 different medications.
You know when you see that
person in say Phoenix Park
or on Grafton Street or Henry
Street and they're like this.
And they're dribbling,
and they've got crumbs
on their top and stuff.
I know it's hard to
believe that that was me.
So never judge a
book by its cover.
I had my face was all
puffy, and I dribbled
with 14 different medications.
And eventually my parents
said, look, it's just not on.
It's not right.
And they asked for
a second opinion.
They pulled a few strings.
They're very good
friends with a doctor.
They pulled a few
strings, and they got me
into another hospital.
And the doctor,
thank god, the doctor
that I was under,
he said, look, I'm
going to talk to different
people who have seen you.
And he did.
He asked my parents
different questions.
And he looked at my file.
And my dad said, can
you tell me this?
Before the accident,
Donna was absolutely fine.
And after the
accident, she's not
normal is the way he put it.
The accident surely has
something to do with it.
And they said, what accident?
It wasn't in my file.
The scan that was
taken of my brain
had showed on my
left temporal lobe.
It showed a hematoma, which
is bruising of the brain.
That also wasn't in my file.
So on paper, it looked like
something very different.
So I spent another three
months in a psychiatric unit
because they had to take
me off all the other junk
that I was put on.
So it got to a point in my
life where the first time
when I had really
difficult times,
I was given a week to live.
So I was at rock bottom.
And I had to learn to
build myself up again.
Gratitude helped me to get
that, believe it or not.
I started to have to think
about what is it that I do have,
not what I don't have.
But the second
time around, when I
was in the psychiatric
hospital and the doctor
said, I have epilepsy, I
said, I don't have epilepsy.
And I was sick of people
telling me what I have.
And I'm quite stubborn.
And I said, I don't
have epilepsy.
Just give me proof
that I have it.
So he sent down to
the hospital library,
and they both brought up
documents about this thick.
And I sat in the bed.
And honestly, I cried, I'd
say, for about an hour.
And it was just tick,
tick, tick, tick, tick.
All the symptoms that I
was experiencing I had.
So they automatically
jumped to a conclusion
that it was psychiatric
when in actual fact,
the head injury caused a
neurological disturbance
in my body.
And I have epilepsy.
And I still have epilepsy.
So I had to build my
life up from where
I was to where I am today.
And thankfully I've learned
that's a different strategy.
So I learned and worked with
lots of different people
that you consider
very successful.
At 23, I opened up
my first company.
And in the first year, I
turned over a million euro.
Now you might think why am
I even telling you that?
It's just to show you that you
can go from absolute disaster
to being happy and
genuinely confident.
And that's what I'm going
to show you here today.
There's a difference between
being cocky and confidence.
If you want to be
cocky or you one
have that shallow confidence,
just become a good actor.
It's very easy to do.
But if you want to have a
genuine sense of confidence,
where you don't have to
shout about it so much,
you can just be confident
to feel good in yourself,
where you wake up in the
morning with a genuine smile
on your face.
That's what I want you to have.
Would you like to have that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DONNA KENNEDY: OK.
So this is about
you've got to decide.
You've got to look at your mind.
And I'm going to show
you how it works.
And then you've got
to decide whether you
need to change your mind,
which is what I had to do.
And this is a question
you need to ask yourself.
Are you becoming a
victim or a victor?
Everything happens
to everybody in life.
Different things, but
at the end of the day,
stuff happens to us.
It doesn't have to be majorly
traumatic or anything.
Stuff happens.
But if you wanted to get
to where you want to get,
you need to decide are
you going to become
a victim of your
circumstance or a victor.
You may not know how to get
what it is that you want,
but the how was just a
strategy that can be learned.
You've got to make the decision
first to become a victor.
So which are we going
to be in the room?
Victors or victims?
AUDIENCE: Victors.
DONNA KENNEDY: Hands up anyone
who would like to be a victim.
Look around the room.
Admittedly are some
of you-- you don't
have to put up your
hands-- admittedly
are some of you looking or are
feeling like a bit of a victim,
blaming the worst
for your problems?
If only they would do
this, then I could do this.
If only I came from
a better background,
I could achieve more.
If only I had better brains
or more intelligence,
I would be better or whatever.
We're constantly
doing comparisons
because we are a society of
comparisons in my opinion.
So it's so important
that you literally
take ownership of your own
life and your own choices
no matter what
background you have,
no matter where you
came from, who you know,
or what your current
circumstances is.
If you want to improve and get
to where you want to get to,
that's what you need to decide.
And you've all
decided here today
that you're going to be victors.
So here's what you've got to do.
You've got to decide
and own your own life.
And I put business up there.
Simply, it can
refer to your career
or if you have a
business or whatever.
You need to choose
and you focus.
So when I was sitting on
my bed, and I was crying.
And I thought, OK, I've
got to do something here.
I didn't want to get
back to baseline.
I want to go more than
that because I thought,
I'm not going back
to where I was.
But I knew how to get there
from the first set of events,
let's say.
But I guess it was
harder the second time
because when you're not back
once and twice and you think,
well, maybe it'll happen again
or something will happen again,
it's a natural question.
But I had to decide.
I had to get
stubborn with myself.
And I had to say, quit the crap.
And really just
own your own life
and become responsible
for your own life.
Become greater
than your problems.
This is what I want
you to understand.
You are not your problem.
If you make your
story your identity,
you will never do anything
worthwhile in your life
ever, not to the full extent
that you can really achieve
what it is that you want to.
So decide what you do want.
Most people look at
what they don't want.
Well, I don't want
to be sad anymore.
Or I don't want
to be shy anymore.
I don't want to be
anxious anymore.
I don't want to be this,
that, or the other.
If you want to get what
it is that you want,
you've got to
decide with clarity
what it is that you want.
You're all Googlers.
If you decide you want to
search something in Google,
do you put in something
that you don't want?
This kind of dumb, isn't it?
So you've got to put in
exactly what you want.
So you've got to tell
yourself what you want.
Put yourself in a strong state.
Look at the
resources around you.
You have so many resources.
What can you use no matter
how small to get you
to where you want to get to?
And create a why.
I put that back there as well.
If you've got a why
to do something,
you will do anything.
How many people
here admittedly get
in better shape when they have a
holiday or a wedding coming up?
They go, well, I'm not going
to sit on the beach looking
like everybody else is there out
there with their beach bodies.
And it gives you a
motivation to do it.
Admittedly, are we
a bit like that?
If we want to give
up cigarettes,
we have to put up
a why behind it.
So when you get a
why, when you get
a bit of an engine behind what
it is that you want to do,
you'll be able to
do it a lot easier.
So look at what it
is that you want
to do if you can identify it.
If not, just play around with
what you might like to do.
And put a why behind it.
So I had to get a why
behind getting better.
My why was I was sick of
seeing my parents cry honestly.
And then I thought, I'm
going to be stubborn,
and I'm going to get what
it is that I want to get.
But I've got to get my why.
And that was my initial why.
So get an initial why,
and then build it up.
This is what you've
got to decide, too.
Are you going to be
interested or committed?
How many people here turned on
their computer this morning?
Were you interested in
doing it, or were you
committed to doing it?
Try and put your
hand up, please.
AUDIENCE: For which question?
DONNA KENNEDY: Try and put
your right hand up then.
AUDIENCE: For what?
DONNA KENNEDY: OK, just try
and put your right hand up.
I'm not asking you whether
you're interested or committed,
try and put your right hand up.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, I said try.
I didn't say put it up.
OK, most people will put it up.
Try and doing are two
totally different things.
If you want to get a result,
you've got to commit to it.
You don't have to be interested.
I can get into my
car and go, oh,
I'm so interested in driving.
Yeah, maybe I'll do it.
Maybe I won't.
Or I'll say, put
the key in and just
put my foot on the accelerator.
Then you then you get somewhere.
So you have to become
not interested.
You need to become committed
to what you're doing.
Remember these three Ps.
I don't know how well
they're highlighted here.
Plan, prepare, and proceed.
Google Maps-- if you want to get
somewhere, you need to decide.
First of all, you
need to type it in.
You need to decide.
It decides for you which is
the best route to get there.
That's smart, isn't it?
If you don't decide
where you want to go,
you'll end up either nowhere or
somewhere you don't want to be.
So identify the best
route to get there.
Look at the skills and
the support that you need.
Now imagine driving a car.
If I'm driving a car, I've got
certain boundaries in the car.
I need to make sure that I've
got things with me in case
I break down.
Or I've got some resources, or
I've got some maybe telephone
numbers that I can ring
in case I break down
or in case I hit an obstacle.
That's smart, isn't it?
Most people don't put
those in their lives.
Most people do not prepare
for if something happens,
what will I do?
So for example, let's say I
meet an event in my life, which
is very likely, where
my life was totally out
of control for
whatever reason or I
perceive it to be that way.
Do you think I could go
back to the way I was?
Absolutely, I could.
Do you think I will?
No way.
And the reason I won't is
because first of all I've
chosen not to.
I've committed not to.
But most importantly, I
have strategies in place
that if I feel like that
way, if I feel vulnerable,
I know exactly what
to do to prevent me
from going back there.
So this is why
you've got to have
strategies and skills
in place to get you
to where you want to go.
Focus forward.
If you're driving a car--
do most of your drive here?
OK, if you don't drive,
you've been in the car
with somebody who does drive.
If they drove looking in
their rear view mirror,
what would you think of them?
Let's drive.
What would you think?
They're insane, right?
So you'd want them
to focus forward.
Most people in the
lights focus backwards.
Their constantly looking
in the rear view mirror.
Well, I want to do this,
but this happened before.
Or I wanted to do this, but it
didn't work out the last time
or whatever.
Focus forward on
what you do want.
If you meet obstacles
along the way, so what?
That's life.
You just learn how
to overcome them.
If you need to
overcome them, you
get that help to overcome them.
But everyone has
those obstacles.
But as long as you're focusing
forward in the right direction.
You have a good
chance of getting
to where you want to go.
I have done here
"choose your team."
Most people in their lives
do not choose their team.
Imagine if you're in a car, and
you've got a bunch of people.
And one is shouting
at you from the back.
One is firing papers at you.
One is putting their
hands over your eyes.
What would you say to them?
Stop, or get out of the car.
So imagine that your
life is like a car.
You either have to tell
people to stop or remove them.
I don't mean kill them.
I mean I just remove them.
[LAUGHTER]
Not delete them,
just a disclaimer.
But just maybe to
step aside from them
or limit your time with them.
If people aren't in
line with or matching
what it is that you want to do--
now here's the thing.
Everybody has a family.
So some of us have bigger
families than others.
And I have what you might
call [INAUDIBLE] all sorts.
They're not all pro my goals.
Some of them think they're mad.
Some of them are
very straightforward.
Some of them are very straight.
Some of them are very
hippy-like or whatever.
But I've got to choose who
I need to have in my life.
Family you can't
really get rid of.
So just limit your time with
the ones that you don't enjoy.
[LAUGHTER]
With the ones--
you can blame me.
But choose who you
want to be around.
But that's not a snobbery thing.
At the end of the day,
there's a phrase, which
I think is a wonderful phrase.
If you're in a plane and the
pressure drops, what do you do?
Put on your own air mask first.
If you're not looking
after yourself,
you can't look
after other people.
Everyone has their own
individual's lives to lead.
And they are responsible
for their own lives.
So stop being responsible
for their lives.
Be responsible for your own.
Own your own life.
And make sure the who you
surround yourself with
are people who
actually are going
to help you get to where
you want to get to.
Find an expert.
This is something
that I had to do.
I had to find experts
because I didn't want
to do it the slow route again.
I wanted to get to where
I wanted to get to,
but I didn't know
how as they said.
So I had to find people who
had what I wanted regardless
of circumstance.
So I thought, what
if I could find
people that had been through
rubbish circumstances
but had become
successful despite them?
And I figured if I
model their results
or if I model
their strategies, I
should come up with
similar results.
That'd be correct?
If I want to be a good chef,
would I find a mediocre chef?
Or would I find
the best if I want
to become really good at it?
You find the best.
So if you want to
do something, you've
got to find the best at it
and model their strategies.
So learn from experts.
When I learned to drive, I made
sure I learned from somebody
who knew how to drive.
It wouldn't be
very smart would it
to learn to drive from
somebody who hadn't a clue
what they were doing?
No.
But most people
learn from people
who haven't a clue
what they're doing.
Believe it or not
in my industry,
there are a lot of people
teaching or explaining,
and they actually
don't have the results
that they're talking about.
You will be shocked.
There are so many
experts teaching stuff,
and they don't have the results.
So for me it's more
important to find somebody--
I don't care what
education somebody has.
I don't care where they're
from, who they know.
As long as they've got the
results that I can follow,
that's what I'm interested in.
And everyone knows one of those.
You may not know
them personally.
If you don't, find them, and
model exactly what they do.
You do not need to
have all the answers.
Nobody does even if they say.
Everybody says, oh, I know
it all in their minds.
No, you don't.
Is there any know-alls here?
Everyone's going, yeah, he is.
Yeah, she is.
The fact is nobody
knows everything.
I'm still learning.
Everybody is still learning.
And practice your actions.
There is no point
thinking about something.
You've got to do.
And you've got practice
it and practice it.
Remember when you
first got your computer
and you learned to
use it, are you better
now than you were
at the beginning?
AUDIENCE: Of course.
DONNA KENNEDY: Some
people don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
Think of that image--
council workers.
I hope nobody here is a
council worker part time,
but in the event
that you are, there
is no point staring into a hole.
Staring into a mess
and looking at it
and having all your
other people that you
don't want in your life join you
looking in and saying, oh, god.
That's such a mess.
What will we do?
Let's all join in
and talk about it.
Let's talk about people
who were also there before.
That doesn't get you anywhere.
Your brain is your
most valuable asset.
People learn strategies
all of the time.
So do I. But unless
you have your brain
behind it, your
engine behind it,
it is like turning on a
computer with no power.
You don't get results.
You have to have your
mindset right first.
Mindset equals money set.
Mindset equals blank set.
Everything you do is
based on your mindset.
Do you perform better if
you're feeling better?
If you've had a really,
really crappy evening
and you come into
work and you just
don't want to talk to anybody,
nobody does that, do they?
Everyone has those days.
So you've got to put
power behind what
it is that you want.
And I'm going to show you this
using an analogy of a computer.
You can all relate
to this, right?
Now if I pick up my phone.
And I have here on my phone--
I actually code my phone
because my son likes to get it.
If you look at all of
those apps on my phone,
how do they get there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DONNA KENNEDY: Some were
put on when I got it, right?
And some I put on.
Some apps actually
arrive on my phone.
I have absolutely no idea
where they came from.
Ads for products that
I have no interest in.
They just pop up on my phone.
I don't know how they got there.
But there's something been
downloaded all the time.
You're probably responsible
for some of them.
[LAUGHTER]
Actually that is just--
[LAUGHS]
It was your look in your
face that gave it away.
So I want you to imagine this.
Imagine somebody
as a total novice.
They don't know anything
about computers,
which you were one time.
And we go into a computer store.
And we ask the person in the
store, look, can you help me?
They are the expert.
And they say, no problem.
And they feel wonderful
about themselves.
They come over.
And you say, well, will you
pick out the best computer
for me, please?
So they go and they pick
out the best computer
that they think is the best one.
So this is wonderful.
And you say, well, I
don't have to use emails,
but I hear everyone
else is using them.
So can you just
put that on, too?
And Microsoft Word
or oops, Google.
Put Google on it, put Chrome
on it, whatever you want on it.
I don't know how to use it.
So will you do it?
So they say, no problem at all.
So they put all this stuff on.
And then this happens.
We get home.
We become frustrated.
It's not working.
Things start to crash.
Emails start to
arrive for everything
you could possibly imagine.
I have got emails from
people that I don't know.
I have won the
lottery so many times.
There are people in Algeria who
want to give me a million euro.
I don't know who they are,
but they arrive all the time.
Now if I don't know
anything about computers,
do you think I'd
open those junk mail?
Of course you would
at the beginning.
Now you may not now
because they know better.
But at the beginning you
open everything, don't you?
And programs start to crash.
And we think, is there
something wrong with us?
So imagine when you
first use a computer,
and just stuff wasn't working.
Or even now, if a program
isn't working for you,
it's frustrating, isn't it?
And sometimes you think,
what is wrong with me?
Why can't I just get this right?
So using that analogy, and
I like to use analogies
because it simplifies things.
I want you to imagine the
computer like your brain
when you're born.
When you're born, we
have a basic computer.
We have a basic brain.
We have the ability to learn a
language, the ability to move,
and the ability to feed.
That's it.
How do you think you have
the accent that you have?
You learned it.
And you were constantly
exposed to it.
Some of you here
have been exposed
to a second language rather
than your first language
because you're around it.
And the more you're around
it, the better you get at it.
And all information
comes into us
like apps on the
phone or a computer.
It comes in constantly.
Our accent, our walks.
I got the raw deal.
I got a male accent,
seriously, flat as a whatever.
But everybody has
an accent simply
because it came
in to your brain.
Every opinion you have, every
cultural opinion you have,
every religious
opinion you have,
everything that you
have in your brain
was downloaded either
by your environment
or by somebody else.
You just let it in.
Same way the stuff
gets into my phone.
Somebody put it in there.
Sometimes I download
stuff that isn't good.
But it goes in there.
And that's the exact
same as our brains.
Now this red thing here
represents emotions.
Sometimes our brain
has emotional tags.
And what that means
is you're here.
There's lots of
information going on,
the lights of the fan,
the camera, everything.
You couldn't possibly focus
on it all at the same time.
You would go crazy, right?
So we filter information.
We narrow it down
to the things that
are important to us, the
things that you can focus on,
that you need to focus on.
And sometimes there's emotions
tagged to information.
It's like, I guess,
an app or a CD.
If you imagine--
or a DVD, whatever.
You just put it into your brain.
So if you imagine, you go
through life, for example.
And you get into school.
Before you go to school, you
think you're really smart.
My four-year-old at the
minute, he is a genius
as far as he is concerned.
He actually did a picture
yesterday, and I have to say,
he's very creative.
So I did call him a
genius on Facebook.
He is wonderful.
And I give praise him.
I'm totally biased.
Now what happens when
he goes into school?
Do you think he's going to start
getting color inside the lines?
Make sure you do this correctly.
If you get an A, you are good.
If you get an F,
you're real rubbish.
He gets all different
information.
Hopefully I'll be able to
prevent or at least reframe
some of that.
But he'll get all that stuff.
So we actually monitor and,
I guess, equate how we are
and how valuable we
are in our identity
to our performance
in society and what
society tells us is good.
So let's imagine I'm in
school, and my teacher
tells me that I'm stupid.
Or I get an F, or I get
it a G, or whatever.
And automatically
my brain tells me
that means I'm not good enough.
So I download it, and
it's emotionally tagged.
Now here's the thing.
All of our senses are involved
in this, our feelings,
what we see, everything.
So it goes in almost
just like a movie.
It goes into our
minds, and it plays.
If there's a lot of emotion
tied to it, it would play a lot.
If there's not
really much emotion,
you probably don't
even notice it.
Our brain's purpose is to
keep us alive and safe.
It likes to keep us comfortable.
So if it recognizes
something in the environment
that it doesn't like,
it will try to avoid us,
or it will try and deal with us.
That's called fight or flight.
So if we have an emotional
tag to a piece of information
or to something that
happens in our lives that
makes us feel uncomfortable,
if we come across that again
or something similar, your
brain has to generalize.
How did you know to
sit on that chair?
Because you've sat in a chair
before and you know what
a chair does.
How do you know when
you walk into a door
that it opens this
way or that way?
The first time you walked
into a door or into the door,
through the door,
the first time you
did that maybe when
you were a baby,
you had to figure out
what does this do.
But our brain generalizes.
Generalize is
positive and negative.
So for example, when
that happened to me
when I was younger, it
was a one-off event.
There was lots of emotions
obviously tagged to it.
But my brain, in order to
keep me safe and comfortable,
said, from now on, if I
experience anything like this
again, trigger all
those same emotions.
And then I have a chance to
decide what to do with them.
So can you imagine if I
went into a situation,
and I got bullied?
Which is control taken
away from me as well.
How do you think I'd react?
Now if you imagine, if
somebody started to ask me
where are you going and
what time would you be back,
do you think that might
have bothered me then?
Yeah, because I felt
they were controlling me.
They probably weren't.
But I felt that they were.
So it generalizes.
It's like a Hoover.
It sucks everything up and then
says, from now on, anything
I see or hear of smell
or taste or feel,
I'm going to trigger
those same emotions.
And that is why if
somebody, for example,
is afraid to give
a presentation,
it's probably because at
some point in your life,
you would have seen or
experienced judgment
at a presentation and
you didn't like it.
Or you saw somebody that
maybe people laughed at
or something like that.
If you're afraid
to do something,
it's because somewhere
in your mind,
you've got a CD playing or a
movie playing that tells you
if I did this, this
is what happens.
We all got those?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DONNA KENNEDY: Everybody does.
That happens in
the limbic system.
The limbic system is basically
really primitive part
of the brain.
Apes have it.
I'm not saying we came
from apes, by the way,
I'm just saying that
it's as primitive.
It's as dumb as an ape.
It's very black and white.
It doesn't see the difference,
reasoning, or nothing.
Reasoning is in a different
part of our brain .
So it's all to do with
emotions, to do with memories,
to do responses, to do with
reward and desire, memories,
everything.
It's all banked in
the limbic system.
And what it does--
this is how it works.
And this is really important
that you pay attention to this.
It can't tell the difference
between what's real or imagined
at a neurological level.
Admittedly, and guys can admit
this, too, if you're in a movie
or watching a DVD and
it's a horror movie
and all of a sudden
something starts to happen.
And your heart starts to
beat, and your sweat glands
start to activate.
And your blood pressure goes up.
And you're like, oh, god,
I don't want to see this.
Even though you know
it's green screen.
It's all special effects.
And they're acting.
So why would your body
physically respond?
Because on a neurological level,
the limbic system cannot tell
the difference between
what is real or imagined.
So it responds anyway.
And the more a body physically
responds to something,
the more adrenaline and
cortisol is released.
The more we shy away from things
if the emotion is negative.
Also it does not
filter information.
Now do not, and I'm
telling you, do not,
think of a pink elephant.
I said, don't.
Now whatever you
do, I don't want
you to think of Grafton
Street, and you're going up.
And wow, there's a red
dress in the shop window.
And then all of a sudden
you see a yellow football
on the ground.
Don't think of that.
We've all thought of it, right?
So our brain doesn't
differentiate.
it's like a junk mail.
Everything just comes in.
It's up to us what we engage in.
But everything comes in.
So everything
somebody says to you,
you register almost
like as a download.
It's up to you
what to do with it.
But if you've got
these programs going on
in your head that are
emotionally tagged,
it makes it deal with it
ineffectively as I did.
Here's the other thing.
It is responsible, as I said,
for the fight or flight.
Do I deal with it,
or do I run away?
Programs or behaviors
and habits, and it
strengthens responses
through repetition.
If I have a dumbbell here and I
do that, it strengthens my arm,
right?
But I won't really
know what [INAUDIBLE]
because it's only done once.
What if I keep doing it?
What happens?
You're all judging
my arm right now.
No, I do not go to
the gym too much.
But it's supposed
to get stronger.
You all speak the
language you speak
because you've practiced it.
You all can do this because
you've practiced it.
The more you do it, the
better you get at it.
And this includes our
thinking and our mindset.
The more we talk to ourselves--
admittedly, have you ever felt
a bit of a sniffle like a cold
and you didn't really
want to go into work
or you didn't want
to do something?
And it's oh, god, I
have an awful cold.
I can feel my
sinuses blocking up.
Yeah, I think my throat
is going as well.
And you start coughing.
And you start actually
talking yourself into it.
We do it all the time.
We don't even realize.
That part of the brain is like
an engine in the background.
We don't realize it's happening.
So this is about becoming
conscious of what you're doing.
Become very aware of
what you're doing.
And things can change.
Change perspective.
Normally I don't
wear sunglasses,
so I thought I'd put
them there just in case.
I mean, you stand up
for a minute, please?
Oh, no.
If you were four, do you
think you'd mind standing up?
AUDIENCE: No, I wouldn't.
DONNA KENNEDY: No, OK.
Put those on.
Turn around.
She looks lovely, doesn't she?
Now just turn around
there for a second.
The room is the
way it is, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DONNA KENNEDY: Now
how does it look now?
AUDIENCE: A lot darker.
DONNA KENNEDY: A lot darker.
Now can you imagine
if she walked around
with the sunglasses
what she would look at
and what she would see?
Let's take them off now.
OK, and sit back down.
What we see in the
world is predicted
by what filter we have.
If I walk around, for example,
with this phone in front
of my eyes, all my
downloads, that's
how I'm going to see the world.
So it's not
necessarily the people
think of you a certain way.
If you programs running in your
mind, you think that they do.
You perceive that they do.
Cultural differences,
race differences,
everything from the
way people look,
the way people dress,
the way people speak,
we all perceive
that they're going
to be a certain way
because of our downloads.
Because of the information
we grow up with,
we perceive various
different things.
So do you think that
I could perceive
that people were controlling my
life after that event happened?
Absolutely.
Were they controlling my life?
No.
When somebody said to me when
I was at my lowest weight,
and someone said, Donna--
and I was getting back up--
you're starting to look
better, I hated them.
I absolutely hated them.
Yet to look a little bit
better would probably
be healthier, right?
So it didn't make any sense that
I wouldn't want to look better.
So I used to think everybody
was telling me if they said,
I looked better, it meant
they were telling me
I was fat, which was
just a perception.
That's all.
So everything that
you do in your life
is a perception of reality.
It's not necessarily reality.
Does that make sense?
So you've got to change the
perceptions that you have
and open your mind
to new thinking.
Open your mind to
different opinions.
different ways of looking
at what you want to achieve
and how you might achieve it.
Understand the perspective
is not the same as a reality.
And this is a question
you need to ask yourself.
Are you prepared to allow your
perceptions or your programs
to determine what
you do in your life?
If somebody called
you stupid, are you
prepared to allow them to
control what you achieve?
If you grew up in a
really disadvantaged area,
are you going to allow that to
dictate how wealthy you become?
If you decided that
you want a promotion
but you don't think you can
because your sister told you
that you probably
won't get it, are you
going to allow that to
dictate what you do?
That's your decision, that
you have to own your life
and allow yourself
to make decisions
based on your new reality
if that makes sense.
And this is neurological, guys.
This is not me just
talking theory.
This happens for real.
You are literally being
wired every single minute
of your day.
As I've been talking, you've
been thinking different ways.
You've been reframing stuff.
You've been thinking, well,
how does that apply to me?
Or how could I use
that in the future?
How could use it in this
circumstance, right?
So when you're
doing that, you're
changing your perception.
And all that takes
is bringing experts
into your life that
have good ones.
Literally choosing the downloads
that you get in your brain,
choosing who you talk to.
If you talk to miserable
people all day,
guess what you're going to feel.
Miserable.
Here's the fix.
You go home from work.
Yay.
"EastEnders," half an
hour, "Coronation Street"
after it I think, "Fair
City" at some point.
Then you watch maybe
the news, or you
might hear the news every hour.
Remember your body is
physically responding.
So if you're watching somebody
scraping somebody else's eyes
out on the pavement
over a row over someone
who's had an affair or you're
watching the news every hour,
your body is physically
responding and wiring you
neurologically.
My body was wired neurologically
for unproductive responses.
So if you want
something in your life
or your career, whatever
it is, that's up to you.
You have to wire yourself
correctly for it.
The only things you should
be putting in your mind
is positive information,
productive information--
everything you read, who
you talk to, what you watch.
And it does have a difference.
I am living proof
that has a difference.
I used to talk myself miserable.
I used to say everything to
myself that I could possibly
say that was negative.
But once I started to seek
out experts or people who
knew what they were
doing, successful people--
successful basically
to me is being
the best you can be in
whatever area you choose.
So what if I was to
find those people
and let them download on
me, let them tell me what it
is that I need to be wired for?
Do you think that would
be a smarter move?
OK, so think about who it
is that you can learn from.
You may not
personally know them.
Read about them.
Some of you have my book.
Read it.
Do it.
There's exercises in it.
Look at people on TV.
How do they walk?
How do they talk if
they feel confident?
If I walk along
like this, do you
think my neurology will
make me feel confident?
Absolutely not because
here's the thing--
your body and your mood
are directly related.
It's called a
psycho-cybernetic loop.
If I look down
like that, my body
will tell me that posture
matches feeling bad.
If I curl in like that, if I
want to do something really
well, if I gave a
presentation like that,
how do you think I'd give it?
Or if I sat down like this
and I walked over like this,
how do you think I'd
give that presentation?
Not strong.
For example, do you want
to engage with new people?
Or you want a new relationship.
Or you want to
learn something new.
Make yourself in that posture.
Think if I knew someone who
was really good at this,
and you may know of them,
how would they stand?
What tone of voice
would they have?
How would they breathe?
At one point in my
life, I was literally
afraid to cross
the road on my own.
I had to get my mother
to hold my hand.
Before that, I didn't want
to go outside my door.
I used to go under my bed.
As my mother called it, I
used to go into my hole.
And for me, I have
to do it gently.
So I had to go in for a cup of
coffee, which was terrifying.
I would genuinely have preferred
to chew on glass than do that.
How am I up here talking to you?
I had to decide.
I had to become committed.
I had to get the skills
and practice them often
till I become wired for it.
So then it becomes as
natural to me as breathing.
And every single thing
that you want to do,
you can do this just by
wiring yourself for it.
So assess your current life.
Assess the downloads you're
putting into your brain.
If you're literally working
on your laptop, and you're
looking at things.
You're typing in stuff
that's negative all the time.
Or you're typing in
crappy codes if you
are trying to learn something.
How do you think
you're going to feel?
So why do it for real?
Because we have become
conditioned to do it naturally.
In our island
especially, and I'm
sure it is across the
world, it's almost bad
to become successful.
The minute someone
becomes bankrupt, yes.
They've lost all their property.
I'm so delighted because
they were greedy anyway.
And all of this stuff.
We celebrate people when
they fail because it
makes us feel more comfortable.
Now in saying that,
I don't anymore.
I love it when
people are successful
and people are happy
and achieve their goals
because they think differently.
And they look at
people differently.
Imagine people are ringing you.
And I say, do I want
to answer them or not?
Imagine if they're
going to fill my mind
with been talking about somebody
else and being really mean.
Will I answer it?
AUDIENCE: No.
DONNA KENNEDY: No.
So why answer people
or answer messages
or answer information
from the environment
if it doesn't make
you feel good?
Only answer and engage
and open up information
that makes you feel wonderful.
Find it, read it, put
it into your brain,
download it, and practice it.
You can do this as a little tip.
This is something that I do.
And it's very simple,
but it's quite effective.
I want you to imagine a Delete
button in your head, OK?
There it is.
If somebody says something
negative to, and that
includes yourself, if you watch
the news more than every half
an hour or every hour, I
want you to press Delete.
Literally imagine pressing it.
Can you all imagine that
putting in your brain?
If you can't imagine it
visually, look at this
and feel it going
into your brain.
Or hear that sound.
OK, so delete it.
Importantly, you need to replace
it with something positive.
So if for example I say to
myself, I can't afford it
and it makes me feel bad, how
about reframing it and saying,
how can I afford it?
What do I need to
do to afford it?
It's a different question, and
you'll get a better answer.
The questions you answer
determine the answers.
Sorry, the questions you
ask determine the answers
that you'll get.
If you ask crappy
questions, you're
going to get bad answers.
If you ask better questions
or reframed questions,
guess what you're going to get?
Better answers and
better solutions.
Imagine this.
Hear it.
I want you to imagine it
going into your brain.
I also want you to
do something else.
Who's right-handed here?
OK, this evening or today
if you have them here--
I'm sure you do--
get an elastic band
and put it on your left
hand on your left wrist.
Who's left-handed?
OK, get an elastic band, and
put it on your right hand.
Now here's the thing.
I want you to wear
this for 24 hours.
If anybody asks, say that
lunatic, Donna Kennedy,
made me wear it.
There's a reason.
And people may ask, why
you're wearing elastic bands?
Any time you think something
negative about yourself
or somebody says, I
want you to get this
depending on your
hand, and I want
you to do this and let it
spring back so it hurts.
[LAUGHTER]
It will shock you.
Wear it in the shower,
everywhere for the next 24
hours.
It will shock you how many,
many negative thoughts
you engage in every day.
It is like sitting
at your computer
and opening up negative
emails all of the time
and wondering why you don't
feel good or perform well.
Look at what it is
that you're opening up.
What is it that you want
to hear in your life?
Every single time, no matter
when it is or where it is,
bang it good and hard.
Whack it off your arm and go,
I shouldn't have done that.
Now why am I asking
you to do that?
Not to give you pain,
although it will hurt.
I'm only asking you to do
that because here's the thing.
It's physical.
Your body will go, oh,
I didn't expect that.
So it changes the pattern.
When I'm asking you to put
a positive program in there
or delete your negative
programs and put
a positive one in its place,
your brain doesn't expect it.
Our brain is conditioned
so it just does that.
How many people honestly, if
we left the room and came back,
you'd sit in the same seat?
Now imagine if somebody
else sat in your seat.
Would you go, oh, she
didn't sit in my seat.
Move.
Because we get into
habits so easy.
How many people have their side
of the couch that they sit on
or their mug?
When you go home, you put
your keys in the same place
all the time without
even thinking.
Or you drive home and you don't
realize how you even got there.
You could be thinking
of something else.
Because we do
things on automatic.
And I want you to learn
stuff on automatic
that will help you to be
the best that you can be.
That's going to help you.
Doing this will
actually help you
because it will throw
your brain off track.
It doesn't matter what you
do, whether you slap yourself
in the face, whether you
drink a drink you don't like,
whether you smell something
you don't like as long as it
interrupts your brain.
But I want you to just do that
because it's really simple.
And if you ever do it
again in the future,
put that elastic band back
on and watch what happens.
You will genuinely be shocked
at how much negative rubbish
you're putting into your lives.
So hands up who is going
to become a victor.
Now to physically get it, I
want you to stand up and become
a victor.
Oh, my god.
I'm standing up.
People are looking at me.
Now this time look slightly
above my level just slightly
above eye level as though you're
walking like, I have this got.
Breathe deeply.
Now think of someone who's super
confident and relaxed in a way,
but they've got
genuine confidence.
You might see them on
TV or might know them.
Now think like them.
How would they walk?
How would they breathe?
Will you walk differently.
Now I want you to all, for a
second, look down at the floor.
Put your shoulders in like this.
How do you feel?
AUDIENCE: Bad.
DONNA KENNEDY: OK,
now the back up.
Look slightly above eye level.
And she breathes already.
So sit down.
If you engage your
brain correctly,
you will embrace
the day differently.
You'll start to
behave differently.
But you need to do it often.
This is not a one-time thing.
You need to continually do it
until it becomes automatic.
And I'm going to finish up on
this because I know time-wise.
Get out of your own way.
The only person stopping
you from doing what it
is that you want to do is you.
If you decide and
commit that you're not
going to take any
rubbish anymore,
that you're not going to
settle for second best,
that you want to actually live
the life that you want to live,
why not do it?
What's stopping you?
Every single person who
has achieved anything great
has overcome adversity.
Most people who are
world-renowned, great thinkers,
great achievers--
Einstein failed maths.
Walt Disney was
fired from his job.
Guess why?
For a lack of creativity.
Michael Jordan was thrown
off his basketball team.
All of these people failed.
But here's how I want
you to think of it.
There is no such
thing as failure.
It's feedback.
If something doesn't work out,
go, what can I do differently?
How can I do it differently?
Ask better questions.
And importantly, take action.
If you just wish for
something, it's just a dream.
But if you take action,
it becomes reality.
And that is the gap in between.
I used to wish
for a better life.
Sometimes I prefer to trade
my life for nothing just
to do away with it.
That was then.
Now I make better questions.
I ask better questions.
I make better decisions.
And I focus on better things.
And importantly, I
take action on those.
I don't wish anymore.
If I want to do
something, I don't
have to know how to do it.
I've just got to do
it and find someone
who's done it before me.
Do you all know someone
who has done something
successful before you?
Everybody has.
Everybody knows
somebody like that.
Find the strategies,
and model them.
And keep taking action.
And keep doing it, and
keep doing it, and keeping
do it until you get the
result that you want.
And you will get the
And remember the phrase we are
all born happy and successful.
We are conditioned not to be.
Now that you know
that, I want you
to be your best
version of yourselves
and reach your potential.
And I'd like to thank
you on that note.
[APPLAUSE]
CAROLINE: Thank you so much.
I'm going to open maybe
one or two questions.
And we have only about
three minutes left,
and then we'll go to audience
questions very quickly.
Please wait until I go myself
or John get a microphone to you.
So first question I
want to start with
is after each of
the major events
that you experienced and your
coming back and became really
strong again, there must
have been lots of times
when you wanted to give up.
What strategies did you use?
Or just why didn't you actually?
Why didn't you give up?
DONNA KENNEDY: I didn't give
up because I knew that there
was something better.
I didn't know how to do it, but
I knew that there was something
better.
And I was sick of
seeing my parents upset.
I watched other people
have what I wanted.
And I guess I just knew there
was a slight glimmer there
that I might be able
to do if I could
get the right people behind
me and the right resources.
Who wants that hope?
Because when you've got a bit
of hope, you can do anything.
So that's why I
grasped that hope,
and I also became very grateful
for everything that I have,
not what I don't have.
CAROLINE: You clearly have had
lots of brilliant achievements.
What in your mind has been
your greatest achievement?
DONNA KENNEDY: Having my baby.
CAROLINE: I thought
you'd mention Ashton.
DONNA KENNEDY: It has to be.
CAROLINE: Fantastic.
DONNA KENNEDY: Yeah,
and you know what?
That was bloody painful.
I have to say, it was the
most painful thing ever.
But sometimes it takes a bit
of pain to get great results.
And yeah, that was my
greatest achievement.
I've done all the
other stuff, but that
was my greatest achievement.
CAROLINE: Fantastic.
Any audience questions?
DONNA KENNEDY:
This is the point,
and I said this to
Caroline beforehand,
this is point where everyone
goes, I want to ask a question,
but I can't put
my hand up first.
CAROLINE: I can't
be the first person.
Anyone?
Yes, great.
AUDIENCE: So you made the
analogy of a computer.
And you said that everything is
a app you download or a program
you download.
But don't people,
and even children,
are born with some
premade software?
Like share something
without people teaching them
how to share.
DONNA KENNEDY: You can have that
as a physical-- but then again,
this is neurological.
So we download stuff, but it
becomes part of our neurology.
So for example, if
somebody has down syndrome.
And there's gene 21.
And it's not working
as effectively
as maybe other people.
That's part of their neurology.
That's part of their
genetic makeup.
But I don't believe
that people are
born with emotional been
pessimists or been depressed.
If you look at all
of the research,
every bit of research
that's out there,
it's all based on
behavior and thought.
So what you see
and what you think
will literally affect the
chemicals in your body
and in your neurology.
If I think negatively,
cortisol and adrenaline
are released in my body.
If I think a happy
thought or I look
at something positive, chemicals
such as norepinephrine,
serotonin, which
is antidepressants,
dopamine, they're all
flowed in my body.
And that has a
physical response.
It's where physically we all
look different because we
have different genetic makeups.
But on an emotional
level, it's neurological.
And that can be changed.
Does that answer your question?
CAROLINE: OK, thank you, doll.
Anybody else with one final
question you'd like to ask?
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: Hi, just
a quick question
on-- so we have busy days and
everybody's always running
and always go, go, go.
Do you have any tips
on finding in yourself
that really makes you tick?
And you know, to find
that purpose to go after,
in that sense,
instead of getting
lost in the day-to-day stuff.
DONNA KENNEDY: Set a time.
Set aside time on one
day a week, one hour,
one day a week to
take a pen and paper
and literally write down
on the top "my why."
Why is it that you want to do?
You know what you want to do.
It's just the condition
that's clouding it.
But you know what
you want to do.
Because when you get up
in the morning, you go,
oh, I'd love to do this today.
Or I'd love to do that today.
Or if I said to you, are
you a creative person?
And you go, yes
or no, whichever.
Or are you someone who loves
like an adrenaline buzz?
You'd say yes or no.
You'd know those questions
because they're better
questions to ask yourself.
So what kind of a person am I?
What do I enjoy?
What makes me go, yes, I
really, really enjoy that.
Or are you a people
kind of person?
If you're a people person and
you take on a solitary job,
you're never going
to be happy in it.
So when you start to write
out what is it that's your why
or play around with
it rather than trying
to be stiff with
it, just play around
with what it is
that you want to do.
Then you put the
passion behind it.
You'll only get passion
when you try it out.
Honestly, most people here
and in the rest of the world
don't know what they want
to do simply because they
haven't asked themselves.
If you ask a child,
what do you want to be?
I want to be Superman,
or I want to be a nurse,
or I want to be a
doctor, or whatever.
It's not necessarily that they
do, but in that moment they do.
So they just don't question it.
And the adults go, yay,
oh, isn't that lovely?
That's so cute.
So they get a reward for it.
Or if a child does something,
everyone celebrates.
If a child stands up and walks
and takes the first step,
everyone celebrates.
So if you start asking
yourself positive questions
and then you celebrate
those questions
or reward yourself when you
do something that you love,
your brain will start to
physically respond to it.
There's a part of our brain.
Some people consider a
part of the limbic system.
It's called the anterior
cingulate cortex.
And what that does is that
is responsible for rewards,
impulses, and desires.
And that part of the
brain, especially in women,
activates very, very easily
when you give yourself a reward
and it tags it to the
thing that you're doing.
CAROLINE: OK, thank
you very much.
So for the last 30
seconds, final question
is who inspires you?
DONNA KENNEDY: My mother.
She passed away two years
ago, but everything that she
taught me has inspired me.
Now I know people think, should
be some celebrity or somebody
that's what everybody knows.
But for me being the
best that you can be
and having good
morals and values
and having good integrity,
that inspires me.
I don't care who the person is.
So my mother for sure.
She taught me how to be
grateful for everything
that I have, not in a grateful
for your dinner in a way.
Or there's people
starving somewhere else,
and you should be grateful.
In a way that to genuinely
appreciate if these were gone,
would you give me a billion
euro for your hands?
Not a hope.
But yet everyone just takes
for granted what they have.
Would you give me a billion
euro for your clothes?
Not a hope.
If you had to take them off and
try to go around everywhere.
You might get them to be at
home with whatever transaction.
Would you give me your
eyes for a billion euro?
But most of us think we have
to be grateful for everything
out there, where my mother,
she inspired me to understand.
I suppose at the beginning,
out of desperation,
but to understand that the
stuff that you actually
have if you become
grateful for it,
you actually become
a stronger person.
Every day-- and it's something
that she taught me from when I
was about five--
she said, say 10
things that you're
grateful for every
day, 10 things.
And it's very hard to stop
at 10 once you start going.
I'm grateful for my eyes.
I'm grateful for my hands.
I'm grateful for my big toe.
If it was gone, I'd hate it.
I'm grateful for the
seat that I sit in.
I'm grateful there's heat here.
I'm grateful that we're
in a safe environment.
And the list goes on and on.
But as soon as you
start to do that,
your brain starts to open
up and think differently.
So she inspires me the most.
CAROLINE: That's great.
Thank you very much.
So--
[APPLAUSE]